யோரோக்கில் கடும்பியான பிரச்சினைகள் வருகின்றன. இன்று இட்டாலியில் என்ன செய்திருக்கிறார்கள்?
இட்டாலியைச் சுற்றி நிறைய அயிலென்று இருக்கிறது. அந்த அயிலில் இருக்கும் நம்மை விட, அதிகாமான பேர் இரண்டு வோட்டில் வந்து
பிரச்சினைகள் முசலின்கள் அந்த அயிலிட்டுக்குள்ளை டாஷ் பண்ணி உள்ளே போன்ற அயிலிட்டை கேட்சர் பண்ணிட்டார்
ஜார்ஜ மெல்லவுணியாக்கு பெரிய பிரச்சினை வரும் இந்த பிரச்சினைக்கு மாலமா, அவள் பெரிய பேச்சு எல்லாம் பேசுகிறார்
ஆனால் அதை வரும்பதற்கான சக்தியோ பார்லைமென்றிப் பாவர்வில் இருக்காம் என்பது தெரியவில்லை, அடுத்த தேரத்தில் ஜெயிப்பாளாது தெரியவில்லை, நீங்கள் வெள்ளிக்குப் புட்பாலைப் பாருங்கள், எல்லா தீமும் பிராஞ்சு தீமில் ஒருவன் கூட பிரிஞ்சாளில் இல்லை, விளக்காரன் இல்லை
எல்லாவற்கான அராவ்த்தேசங்களே வந்துவிட்டார்கள், ஆனால் நான் இதை சொல்லும்போது, வைட் மேல் எனக்கு பரிதாவம் வரமாட்டிக்கொண்டு இருக்கிறது.
எனக்கு கர்மா, உலகத்தில் எல்லாம் சுறந்தி இருக்கிறான், உலகத்தில் எல்லாம் கொல்ல எடித்திருக்கிறான், சக்ஜுகேட் பண்ணிக்கிறான்,
இந்த போர்ச்சுகீஸ் வந்து நம் கோவால் 1000, 40,000 வேறை எழிச்சுகொன்னான் கிருஸ்துவனா மாறின்னான், சேன் ஜெய்வியம், புதுச்செய்யில், பாண்டிச்செய்யில், பிரிஞ்சு, நம்ம ஊரில் அவ்வளவா செய்யல, நீங்கள் அவ்ரிக்கன், பிரிஞ்சு, காலினிஸ்லாம் போனால் கதைகள் கேட்கலாம்.
இன்று அந்த கர்மா இந்த ஜெனரேஷனை அப்பேட்டுக்கொண்டு இருக்கிறது. அந்த ஜெனரேஷனை செய்யவில்லை தவறு.
ஏதோ நானும் குருப்சம் முன்னால் உந்தையர்கள் செய்தார்கள். இங்கிலாந்துடன் நிலை என்ன?
பிணாண்சியல் நிலை என்ன? சோஷியல் பொப்புலேஷன் நிலை என்ன?
லொந்தன் மேயிருப்புரு பாகிஸ்டானி துலுக்கன், வைட்சுந்து ரோடுக்கு வந்து ரீ ரீ ரீஜேன் அவருடைய ஈங்கிலாண்டு,
நீங்கள் அவர் ஈங்கிலாண்டு விரைவேண்டும் என்று பிள்ளைக்காட பிடித்துண்டு ஓட்டுவான்.
என்னைக் கொலையாட்சியிருக்கிறான் நம்ம நாட்களை எல்லாம்.
இது கர்மத்தான், அவனைப் பாதிக்க வேண்டும். இது நியாயமா, அடுத்த நிறுவனத்தில் பாதிக்கலாமா?
அப்படின் சொன்னால், கேள்வி இருக்கிறது, ஆனால் பாதிக்கத்தான் பாதிக்கும், அது உண்மையாக இருக்கிறது.
என்ன நினைக்குக்கிறீர்கள்?
கண்டிஸ், ஏதாவது குறிஞ்சுகள் இருக்கிறது? இப்போது ஒரு வார் வருகிறது என்று வைத்துக்கொள்ளுங்கள், அங்கு இருக்கு அனைவரும் அப்படியாக ஆதரவும் அல்லவா, அந்தக் கண்டிரில் இருக்கு அனைவரும் வார்வார்கள்,
பாலோயில் ஒரு பாலோயில் அந்தப் பாடல்கள் அனைவரும் அப்படியாக ஆதரவும் அனைவரும் ஒரே மாதிரி கர்மா செய்திருப்பார்கள் என்று கூறும்போகிறேன், அந்தக் கலெட்டியில் அந்தப் பாடல்கள் அல்லவா,